- [Instructor] What were
going to do in this video
is think a little bit
about place value tables
and sometimes they're referred
to as place value charts.
In previous videos, we've
already talked about
the idea of place value,
and a place value table
or a place value chart
is just a way to say how much we have,
how much value we have in each place
in a very, very clear way.
So, here they say use the place
value chart to write 60,229.
And, this is the place value
table or place value chart
right over here.
They say, enter a digit,
one-digit number in each box
of the place value chart.
So really, all they're saying is
how many 10 thousands do we have?
How many thousands?
How many hundreds?
How many tens?
And, how many ones?
And like always, it's always a good idea
to try to have a go at it
before I do it with you.
So, why don't you do that?
Why don't you pause the video
and on a little piece of scratch paper
say how many 10 thousands are in 60,229?
How many thousands are there?
How many hundreds?
How many tens?
And, how many ones?
All right, now let's do this together.
So, we could start at the left
in the 10 thousands place.
This is the ones place.
This is the tens place.
Let me do that a little bit neater.
So, this is ones, tens, hundreds,
thousands, 10 thousands.
So, we can see that we
have six 10 thousands.
So, all we would do is
say, we'd put a six there.
We have six 10 thousands.
And then, how many thousands?
Well, that would be one
place over to the right.
This is interesting.
We can see very clearly,
we actually have zero thousands.
So, zero thousands.
You might say, hey.
When you say this out you say 60,229.
Don't we have 60 thousands?
Well, you already accounted for that
in the six 10 thousands.
Six 10 thousands is 60,000.
But just in the thousands
place, you have none.
And then, we move on
to the hundreds place.
You can see very clearly
we have two hundreds,
and then we can go to the tens place.
And, I've written over it a little bit,
but we have two tens.
And then last but not least,
we have nine ones.
And, we're done.
And so, the whole point of this video
is to just get you comfortable
with this type of format
with a place value table
or a place value chart,
and all it is,
is a way of really clearly writing out
how much value you have in each place
in a number like this.